- C'était présenté depuis
des mois comme un match revanche
et c'est effectivement une
course à deux qui se confirme.
Denis Coderre recueille
26 % des intentions de vote;
25 % pour Valérie Plante;
Balarama Holness attire cinq
fois moins d'électeurs, à 5 %.
Le reste des candidats
se partagent seulement
14 % des intentions.
Il reste deux semaines pour
se faire une idée et beaucoup
sont comme cette citoyenne.
- Bien là, en ce moment,
je suis en exploration.
Je dis pas à personne encore
parce que ma décision est pas
encore prise, mais... à voir.
- 27 %, plus d'un Montréalais
sur quatre, ne sait toujours pas
vers qui son coeur balance.
RÉMY TRUDEL, professeur, ENAP
- C'est beaucoup, mais c'est
comme aussi une invitation
particulièrement forte pour
les deux partis politiques, là,
d'accentuer les efforts
d'ici le 7 novembre.
- Le sondeur Alain Giguère
constate encore que les jeunes
électeurs sont plus attirés
par Projet Montréal.
ALAIN GIGUÈRE, président de CROP
- Et donc, si les clientèles
plus âgées votent plus pour
M. Coderre et qu'ils sortent
plus pour aller voter, ça peut
avantager grandement M. Coderre,
ça. Le défi de Mme Plante,
d'ici l'élection, c'est de faire
sortir le vote des jeunes.
- Deux grands thèmes émergent
en tête des préoccupations
des électeurs, sécurité
et logement, qui relèguent la
mobilité, pourtant omniprésente
en 2017, au troisième rang.
JEAN-PHILIPPE MELOCHE prof.,
École d'urbanisme, Uni. de Mtl
- Deux thèmes qu'on ne voit
habituellement pas. Et aussi,
il faut dire que les gens
bougent pas, c'est-à-dire
que beaucoup de gens qui sont
en télétravail, ceux qui sont
pas en télétravail ont connu
des conditions de mobilité
particulières dans la dernière
année et demie, ce qui fait
qu'ils sont peut-être moins
fâchés par leurs déplacements.
- Une question mêlait à la fois
des enjeux environnementaux
et de circulation :
"Seriez-vous d'accord que
Montréal restreigne l'accès
au centre-ville aux véhicules
à essence?" Oui à 60 %,
ont répondu les personnes
interrogées, qui se prononcent
aussi très largement
en faveur du REM de l'Est.
Mais ils sont plus nombreux
à souhaiter qu'il y ait
une portion souterraine
au centre-ville.
- Bonjour!
- Quant à la satisfaction
globale de l'administration
sortante, près d'un Montréalais
sur deux se dit très
ou assez satisfait.
- C'est pas comme si on avait
un taux très élevé
d'insatisfaction.
Et là, on défait quelqu'un,
ce qui avait été un peu
le cas à l'époque où M. Coderre
est parti parce que, là,
l'insatisfaction était
assez élevée à l'époque.
C'est pas le cas du tout
à l'heure actuelle.
- Reste à faire sortir
les électeurs de chez eux,
que ce soit pour voter
par anticipation, les 30 et
31 octobre, ou le 7 novembre.
Le taux de participation
aux élections de 2017 n'était
que d'un peu plus de 42 %.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, M